hablamos del modelo de board del átomo
de hidrógeno y sabemos que el átomo de
hidrógeno tiene una carga positiva en el
núcleo aquí está el núcleo con carga
positiva y un electrón con carga
negativa y si vemos el modelo de board
veremos que el electrón con carga
negativa está orbitando el núcleo a
cierta distancia
aquí estoy poniendo al electrón a una
distancia r 1 por lo que este electrón
está en el nivel más bajo de energía el
estado fundamental del nivel de energía
en uno en el vídeo anterior vimos que
con la cantidad adecuada de energía
podemos promover a este electrón para
que salte a un nivel de mayor energía
así que si agregamos la energía
necesaria podemos hacer que este
electrón llegue a este nivel de mayor
energía de manera que ahora está a una
distancia r 3 del núcleo que corresponde
al nivel de energía 3
es el proceso de absorción el electrón
absorbe energía y salta a un nivel más
alto de energía aunque esto es algo
temporal pues el electrón no se quedará
ahí para siempre
eventualmente regresará al estado
fundamental vamos a poner esto en el
diagrama de la derecha aquí está nuestro
electrón en el tercer nivel de energía y
eventualmente el electrón caerá de
regreso al estado fundamental del primer
nivel de energía y cuando el electrón
hace esto va a emitir un fotón va a
emitir luz así que cuando un electrón
pasa a un nivel de menor energía va a
emitir luz y a eso le llamamos emisión y
con esta línea curveada representó al
fotón que es la forma más común de
representar a un fotón en los libros de
texto así que emite un fotón que tendrá
cierta longitud de onda lambda es el
símbolo de la longitud de onda y tenemos
que encontrar cómo relacionar lambda con
estos diferentes niveles de energía
la energía del fotón emitido es igual a
la diferencia de energía entre esos dos
niveles de energía entre el nivel de
energía 3 y el nivel de energía 1 la
diferencia de energía entre el 3 y el 1
es igual a la energía del fotón y
sabemos que la energía de un fotón es
igual a h niu h es la constante de
planck y miu es la frecuencia queremos
pensar en longitudes de onda por lo que
necesitamos relacionar la frecuencia con
la longitud de onda y la ecuación que
hace esto es c igual a lambda niu
se es la velocidad de la luz lambda es
la longitud de onda y miu es la
frecuencia si despejamos la frecuencia
esta será igual a new igual hace entre
lambda
tomamos todo esto y lo sustituimos aquí
para obtener la energía del fotón que es
igual a la constante de planck h
multiplicada por la frecuencia que es
igual a c / lambda la energía del fotón
es h por c / lambda en lugar de usar el
3-1 pensamos en niveles de energía
genéricos así que llamemos a este
j y al nivel de menor energía al que
llega el electrón le llamaremos e y en
lugar de usar el 3 y 1 usaremos la
anotación más genérica de j
pongamos la aquí la energía del fotón
será igual al nivel de mayor energía j
menos el nivel de menor energía y ahora
tenemos esta ecuación que voy a resaltar
aquí h por c sobre lambda igual a j - y
hagamos más espacio para tratar de
despejar esto un poco mejor y vamos a
reescribir la función
en el vídeo anterior les mostré cómo
calcular la energía de cualquier nivel
de energía y encontramos esta ecuación n
n es cualquier nivel de energía es igual
a 1 / n al cuadrado
si queremos conocer la energía de j será
1 / j al cuadrado
tomamos esto y lo sustituimos aquí
si quiero conocer la energía del menor
nivel tendré
que es igual a 1 / y al cuadrado
tomamos esto y lo sustituimos acá
hagamos más espacio y escribamos lo que
tenemos h por pse entre lambda
es igual a 1
/ j al cuadrado
- 1 / y al cuadrado
aquí podemos factorizar es 1 y nos queda
h porsche entre lambda igual a 1 que
multiplica a 1 entre jota al cuadrado
menos 1 entre y al cuadrado
ahora dividimos ambos lados entre hc y
nos queda uno entre lambda igual a 1
entre hc
que multiplica a 1 / j al cuadrado menos
1 / y al cuadrado
en un vídeo anterior calculamos cuánto
vale 1 y lo sustituimos acá uno entre
lambda es igual a menos 2.17 por 10 a la
menos 18 pueden ver este cálculo en
dicho vídeo lo que nos llevó cierto
tiempo de realizar todo esto entre h c
que multiplica a 1 / j al cuadrado
- 1 / y al cuadrado
veamos con más detalle lo que tenemos
aquí si ahora no me preocupo por el
signo negativo
todo esto es igual a una constante pues
h es la constante de planck que es la
velocidad de la luz así que tenemos
todas estas constantes de aquí por lo
que podemos reescribir todo esto como
solo r vamos a reescribir la 1 entre
lambda es igual a menos r
por uno entre jota al cuadrado
- 1 / y el cuadrado
r es llamada la constante de river
r es igual a 2.17 por 10 a la menos 18
que es en 1 / 6.626 por 10 a la menos 34
que es h
y multiplicado por 2.99 79 por 10 a la 8
que es la velocidad de la luz y si
hacemos los cálculos nos da que r es
igual a 1.09 por 10 a la 71 entre metro
quizá tuve un problema de redondeo aquí
ya que si usamos 2.18 será mejor y
tendremos a 1.097 por 10 a las 7 la cual
es la constante de river
aquí estoy tratando de darles la idea
detrás de la constante de river la cual
tiene este valor y que podemos usar en
lugar de r lo que haremos en el
siguiente vídeo podemos detenernos acá
pues ya hemos relacionado a nuestra
longitud de onda con nuestra diferencia
de niveles de energía o podemos avanzar
un poco más tenemos uno entre lambda
igual a menos r y aquí actualizamos uno
menos uno y cambiamos el orden de los
términos nos queda menos uno entre y
cuadrada menos uno entre jota cuadrada
ahora tenemos estos dos números
negativos lo que nos da un positivo y
nos queda uno entre lambda igual a r por
uno entre y al cuadrado menos uno entre
j al cuadrado
recuerden lo que representan y jota y
representa el nivel de menor energía y
jota representa el nivel de mayor
energía
esta es una ecuación extremadamente útil
y se le llama ecuación balmer risberg y
deducimos esta ecuación usando las
suposiciones del modelo de voz esta
ecuación es muy útil porque nos ayuda a
explicar todo el espectro de emisión del
hidrógeno y esta es la razón por la que
exploramos el modelo de boro en primer
lugar ya tenemos esta ecuación y en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a ver cómo esto
explica el espectro de emisión del
hidrógeno piensen en la longitud de onda
como la luz que es emitida cuando el
electrón cae a estados de energía más
bajos